j'ouvre le second débat de ce sens
public c'est un zoom sur l'intelligence
artificielle et ses effets sur nos
emplois que je vous propose quels métier
sont les premiers à se transformer cette
technologie qui envahit nos nos bureaux
va-t-elle forcément détruire des
millions d'emplois dans le monde comment
apprendre à travailler avec
l'intelligence artificielle dite
générative pour ne pas disparaître à
cause d'elle avant d'entendre nos
experts un reportage dans une entreprise
française l'entreprise enfin une
entreprise qui a des cour en France une
entreprise s'appelle enclusive qui est à
courbevie plan de licenciement de près
de la moitié des salariés français ils
seront remplacés par un logiciel Audrey
betaz Denis est l'une des premières
victimes de la guerre entre les humains
et les machines depuis 30 ans il écrit
des revues de presse pour des
institutions publiques françaises ou des
sociétés du CAC 40 dans 3 mois son
entreprise va le remplacer par une
intelligence artificielle qu'il n'a
jamais vu est-ce qu'une machine sera
encore une fois faire la part du Bien du
Mal sens la nuance d'un discours quand
quelqu'un ment ou quoi que ce soit dans
entreprise on insiste toujours sur la
loyauté des employés par rapport à sa
direction par rapport à entreprise et
finalement on sent qu'on va être bon on
passe par perd des profits c'est pas un
sentiment agréable en tout sa société
inclusive va supprimer la moitié de ses
effectifs en France 217 emplois très
qualifiés sur 447 une mesure justifiée
selon elle par un tournant technologique
pour assurer sa pérenité nous
introduisons de nouvelles technologies
de nouveaux outils qui offriront à nos
clients un service plus rapide et plus
fiable cela inclut l'apport de
l'intelligence artificielle cependant
tout programme de transformation de
cette ampleur nécessite des décisions
difficiles y compris un plan de
licenciement associé enclusive annonce
que 23 nouveaux postes seront créés pour
tous les autres des négociations ont
commencé entre les syndicats et la
direction des syndicats qui disent
vouloir lancer l'alerte ils sont les
premières victimes de l'intelligence
artificielle mais toutes les entreprises
du tertièire pourrai être concerné le
gouvernement nous dit oui ça va créer de
l'emploi aujourd'hui nos outils
d'intelligence ariciel qui sont censé
ils ne sont pas fabriqués en France donc
là l'emploi je le trouve
pas voilà on supprime 217 postes mais
l'outil n'est pas fabriqué en France
donc là la création d'emploi via sur
l'IA je la vois pas chez inclusive les
premiers départs auront lieu dès janvier
2024 l'intelligence artificielle
dernière génération va-t-elle détruire
des dizaines voir des centaines de
millions d'emplois dans le monde c'est
la question centrale de notre débat je
vous présente mes invités Marion carré
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
cofondatrice présidente de la start-up
askma et enseignante à Scien Po Paris
blismao bonsoir bienvenue à vous
confondateur rédacteur en chef du
magazine uzbec et Rica ran Sébastien
Carbonel bonsoir et bienvenue sociologue
du travail et post-doctorant à l'École
normale supérieure de sacelet laéticia
crupa évidemment rester à mes côtés
éitorialiste politique dans la première
et la seconde partie ça n'a pas changé
évidemment tiens un chiffre pour
commencer il va sûrement vous faire
réagir il nous vient de la banque
Goldman sax il date du mois de mars
dernier la banque qui évalue
euh les remplacements de postes lia
pourrait remplacer l'équivalent de 300
millions d'emplois est-ce que vous êtes
aussi pessimiste Marion caré est-ce
qu'on est-ce qu'on est face à une
destruction massive d'emplois faut
d'ailleurs une vraie question aussi de
société le temps qu'on va gagner si on
est remplacé de plus en plus par des
machines c'est une vieille question mais
à quoi on va le à quoi on va le le
l'utiliser à mon sens l'enjeu il est
plutôt sur la transformation des emplois
plus que sur le remplacement il y a
récemment une étude qui a été publiée
par l'Organisation internationale du
travail qui est un organisme des Nations
Unies qui mettait l'accent sur le fait
que effectivement on est face à une
transformation donc ça veut dire qu'on
va avoir des impacts sur la qualité des
emplois la cadence aussi potentiellement
l'intensité plus que sur un remplacement
et en fait sur la plupart des emplois il
y a un certain nombre de de tâches où on
peut être complété par des intelligences
artificielles mais il y a peu d'emplois
dont 100 % des tâes peuvent être
remplacés par des IA et d'autres comme
si on pense par exemple je sais pas au
pompiers ou ce type de métier c'est
c'est complètement impossible de de
substituer par une on reviendra au
détail métier par métier tâche par par
tâche BL Maou des machines qui
remplacent nos nos nos emplo enfin bon
le thème n'est évidemment pas nouveau
sauf que ça touchait plutôt des des
emplois manuels là l'intelligence
artificielle notamment la dernière
génération lié à dit générative c'est
c'est ça ça ça fait valser le débat ça
change le débat en quelque sorte oui ça
change la donne parce qu'effectivement
jusque- là on parlait de machines
remplaçant des emplois physiques
notamment les machines industrielles qui
on remplaçaient les les Coles bleu dans
les usines là chat GPT la nouvelle
génération d'intelligence artificielle
générative c'est une révolution pour
pour l'é colle blanc c'est une
révolution pour les professions
créatives pour les métiers de
journalistes d'illustrateurs de
doubleurs de traducteurs je pense que
c'est c'est ça qui change après c'est je
je rejoins ce qu' dit Marion c'est ni
une totale destruction ni plein de
création d'emploi ça va être un peu des
deux mais ça là les salariés pardon vous
interrompre mais les salariés de de de
l'entreprise enclusive qui qui vous
entendent dire ça vous êtes bien gentil
mais enfin nous là les les les 200 et
quelques emplois ils sont perdus quoi là
ils sont perdus il faut rappeler que
c'est une entreprise qui fait de la
veille média donc peut-être sur une
tâche qui est plus facilement
automatisable que d'autres quoi que on
verra dans le temps faut faut voir où
ils en sont dans un an je pense que ce
qui est intéressant c'est de voir qu'il
y a plein d'entreprises qui ont peur de
rater ce train là et donc qui prennent
des décisions créatives je va prendre un
exemple dans le secteur des médias euh
qu'on connaît bien une un groupe qui
s'appelle ganette américain qui possède
notamment USA Today plusieurs quotidiens
régionaux a déployé cet été unea
génératif pour commenter des rencontres
de foot américain ça a tourné au fiasco
au bout de de quelques commenter
oralement quelques
jours écrit du texte écrit généré
automatiquement un outil assez
comparable à chat GPT Sappel LED ai LED
Ia quoi artificial intelligence et en
fait ça crée des phrases complètement
absurdes du genre une rencontre
athlétique du 3ème type ou un match qui
évite les freins et passe à la vitesse
de la victoire donc on a l'impression
d'un mauvais doublage sur les réseaux
sociaux et et tout le monde RT pédalé
inér progrès de cette pardon vous
interromp les progrès de cette
intelligence itificiel générative ils
sont ils sont dingues quoi c'estd que la
la version une ou alors c'était
peut-être la 2 je sais pas qui donnait
ça mais la version 3 est encore meilleur
la 4 enfin je pense que cet argument là
il vaudra peut-être plus dans un ou de
ans sont très rapides mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est pas seulement de voir
l'inquiétude d'un grand remplacement par
des robots c'est de voir la vitesse avec
laquelle les gens se sont emparés de ces
alors ça c'est une vraie question et on
y reviendra évidemment je reste r
Sébastien Carbonel sur le l'entreprise
qu'on a qu'on a suivi en
reportage l'intelligence artificielle
est-elle la seule responsable finalement
de ce plan de licenciement parce que ça
peut aussi être un argument que des que
des patrons donnent pour pour justifier
des licenciements non vous avez
entièrement raison dans le sens où pour
moi lorsqu'on parle de intelligence
artificielle de nouvelles technologies
de façon générale il faut toujours les
inscrire dans un contexte économique et
dans le cas de cette entreprise
inclusive c'est un plan social en
quelque sorte qui est justifié par de
l'intelligence artificielle et pourtant
l'entreprise perdait déjà des millions
dans la rentabilité dans les chiffres
d'affaires des choses comme ça donc on a
l'impression que l'entreprise utilise ça
comme une excuse et les syndicalistes
eux-mêmes de l'entreprise et enfin
formule plutôt l'hypothèse que c'est un
PS présenter comme un moyen pour que
l'entreprise soit mieux revendue jus
d'accord plan social en en prévision de
N vent mais il n'empêche que ces
salariés ils sont quand même remplacés
par un logiciel par une intelligencepr
je suis d'accord avec ce qu'a dit mon
collègue c'est que rien ne dit que ce
modèle là soit viable sur le moyen terme
par qu'on a présenté des usines du futur
des usines sans salariés sans
travailleurs sans travailleuses mais la
plupart de ces exemples d'usin du futur
appartiennent au passé c'estàdire que la
plupart d'entre elles sinon la totalité
on fermé et on se sont révélés des
échecs retentissant alors quels métiers
sont principalement concernés on va
détailler un peu ce cet aspect des
choses avec d'abord là aussi un chiffre
que je vous propose puisque là on parle
d'une entreprise inclusive bon voilà ça
concernait c'est un drame pour tous ceux
qui ont été licenciés hein je veux pas
sous-estimer mais il y a a 400 et
quelques salariés dans dans dans cette
entreprise à courb voie bref là je vais
vous donner un autre exemple qui est
celui de British Telecom donc là on est
dans un géant de l'économie mondial qui
prévoit de licencier 55000 personnes
d'ici à 2030 et 20 % d'entre elles
pourraiit être remplacé par
l'intelligence artificielle là on est on
est sur une évidemment une autre échelle
de valeur quels métiers sont concernés
vous l'avez cité l'étude de
l'organisation international du du
travail Marion carré on va on va voir
apparaître les métiers moyen ement ou
fortement exposé employés de bureau 58 %
des tâches moyennement exposé 24 %
fortement exposé profession
intermédiaire on est à 25 % des tâches
moyennement exposées profession
intellectuelle et scientifique 25 %
travailleurs des services et de la vente
17 % manager on y reviendra au manager
au patron 13 %. il y a un élément
intéressant Marion caré c'est que dans
dans ces employés de bureau il y a
beaucoup de femmes donc ça veut dire que
les femmes seraient plus impacté par le
déploiement l'intelligence artificielle
dans les dans les prochains mois dans
les prochaines années effectivement vous
touchez un point clé il y a cette étude
qui le mentionne il y en a d'autres qui
corroborent ces chiffres sur le fait de
dire que effectivement ces emplois de
bureau ils sont bah plus plus occupés
par des femmes et que du coup il y a un
impact un impact plus important pour
pour les femmes et c'est vrai que c'est
un enjeu où en fait ensuite une fois
qu'on on s'intéresse métier par métier
en fonction de la répartition et
notamment du type de tâche attendu par
exemple les travaux qui sont plus anal
ti sont plus susceptibles d'être d'être
remplacés donc c'est vrai qu'ensuite
tâche par tâche composante par
composante ça a des impacts différents
alors je je vrais vous entendre sur ce
que ça parce qu'on peut aussi retourner
la question là on est volontairement
peut-être un peu négatif en disant
attention centaines de millions
d'emplois menacés dans le monde et
cetera en reprenant les chiffres de
Goldman sax mais on peut aussi
considérer que ce sont des tâches pas
forcément très intéressantes qui seront
occupé ou rempli par par des robots ou
de l'intelligence artificielle est-ce
que vous êtes sur cette ligne là je
pense que c'est ça qui va intéressant de
voir c'est la manière dont on
s'approprie ces outils aujourd'hui ceux
qui se les sont déjà appropriés depuis
le début de l'année on pu voir les
limites et les avantages de chat GPT par
exemple prend l générative oui parce qu'
il est un peu partout faut rappeler que
Microsoft a racheté ou en tout cas
fortement investi dans dans l'entreprise
qui qui sort Open qui sort CHP besoin
des serveurs on a cette technologie
enfin moi je l'utilise pas mais bon on a
cette technologie sur le le Microsoft
365 par de faire de la pub he mais qui
qui est utilisé par des millions et des
millions de de personnes dans le monde
donc il y a des millions et des millions
d'utilisateurs déjà de cette technologie
Google est sur sur une une offre
concurrente et ceter et ch GPT c'est 1
million d'utilisateurs en 5 jours quand
il est les 5 premiers jours de son
ouverture au grand public 100 millions
en 2 mois c'est plus que aucun outil
aucune plateforme technologique dans
l'histoire jamais noué s fait à une
place aussi vite en 2 mois aucune il y a
jamais autant de early adopteurs comme
on dit d' d'une d'une app c'est gratuit
ou pas alors il y a une version gratuite
qui est évidemment pas la version la
plus compète
et les utilisateurs premium ont accès
depuis quelques jours à une version qui
permet de parler et de générer de la
conversation à partir de photos donc il
y ça va très vite effectivement pour
rejoindre ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
après je pense que ceux qui n'ont pas
utilisé ces outils là sont vraiment dans
un fantasme de remplacement et ceux qui
qui ont commencé à s'en emparer sont
capables de de distinguer ce qui est
utile ce qui est précieux et ce qui est
vraiment pénible votre avis sur la
qualité des tâches réservées aux humains
Sébastien Carbonel est-ce que
effectivement l'intelligence
artificielle c'est ces nouvelle
génération vont nous permettre de nous
délester des des tâches rébarbatives ou
pas alors à mon avis il faut faire une
distinction importante tout d'abord
entre emploi et tâchees et quand on
parle de remplacement de substitution on
fait cette confusion là et comme l'a dit
Marion carré les nouvelles technologies
au travail ce qu'elles font c'est
qu'elles remplacent certaines tâches et
non pas nécessairement des emplois et
donc elles viennent complémenter ouord
augmenter le travail des travailleuses
et des travailleurs et donc modifier et
là en mieux ou pas ah c'est ça c'est ce
que j'allais dire c'estd que en général
c'est pas forcément en mieux pourquoi
parce que il y a des dynamiques de
déqualification puisque ces nouvelles
technologies prennent en charge une
partie des qualifications qu'avaient ces
salariés là euh c'est un peu
contreintuitif pour moi honnêtement
parce que je suis surpris mais non non
mais parce que parce que voilà on se dit
si c'est une tâche répétitive pas très
intéressante voilà autant se concentrer
sur sur l'autre partie de son métier
vous voyez ce que je veux dire oui oui
tout à fait non plus une tâche est
répétitive plus facile elle est enfin
plus facilement elle est automatisable
ça c'est vrai c'est ce que disent la
plupart des économistes et cetera mais
les directions d'entreprise peuvent
aussi utiliser ces nouvelles
technologies pour augmenter leur
contrôle sur le processus de travail et
donc pouvoir décider plus facilement le
rythme de travail et la façon de
travailler et donc on voit bien comment
ces nouvelles technologies peuvent avoir
une dynamique de déqualification sachant
que la déqualification n'est pas
unilatérale et il peut y avoir également
dans certains cas des formes de
requalification mais ce sont souvent des
nouveaux métiers disons un peu
minoritaires par rapport à à la masse de
des qualification des salariés mais vous
vous conseillez quoi Marion carré à T
celles et ceux qui nous qui nous
regardent que qu' soit actif ou pas
retraité ou pas chef d'entreprise ou ou
ou ou simple
salarié de d'essayer et d'apprendre ou
c'est ça vous semble essentiel
aujourd'hui moi j'aimerais bien rebondir
sur la problématique de la
déqualification avec un empoi
concret effectivement des points de
discord avec lors de cette grève des
scénaristes à Hollywood oui alors
j'allais venir au méti créatif mais les
scénaristes un des points discord
c'était finalement est-ce qu'ils
allaient se retrouver en position de
relire des textes créés par des
intelligences artificiel et c'est vrai
que là on a une déqualification parce
qu'on passe d'un acte de création à un
acte de relecture ce qui est
effectivement moins qualifié donc
heureusement
c'est aussi sur lesquels ils ont pu
l'emporter alors je vais juste ouvrir
une parenthèse et puis je vous laisserai
conclure après euh 5 mois de de de de
conflit c'est en passe de se terminer
puisque c'est aujourd'hui mais ça va
être avec le décalage horaire sans doute
après notre émission que le le plus
puissant syndicat des scénaristes
d'Hollywood va ratifier l'accord qui a
été négocié il nous dit il nous dit ce
syndicat le Writers Guild of America un
compromis exceptionnel qui inclut des
gains significatifs en matière de
rémunération et des protections pour
encadrer l'utilisage l'usage de
l'intelligence artificielle je vous
laisse terminer la démonstration pardon
et je pense qu'on a un enjeu en tant que
société de s'interroger en fait il a ce
qui est techniquement possible et ce qui
est socialement souhaitable et on peut
vraiment se poser la question en terme
de futur désirable sur les tâches qu'on
veut déléguer à l'intelligence
artificielle et celle qu'on veut garder
et quand on délègue qu'est-ce qu'on fait
du temps qu'on gagne et je pense que
c'est un vrai sujet notamment dans les
métiers de service et d'accompagnement
des loisirs pourquoi pas ou peut-être
passer plus de temps à accompagner
certains certains usagers par exemple
dans des emplois publics au contact avec
les usagers donc en fait il y a plein de
réponses sur où est-ce qu'on veut gagner
du temps qu'est-ce qu'on veut garder
qu'est-ce qui est important de laisser
entre les mains des humains et euh
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de ce temps-là je
je vais rester on reviendra au métier
créatif mais je trouve ça passionnant ce
que vous levez donc on va le creuser un
peu ce ce ce thème là Blais Mao c'est
effectivement un enjeu de société mais
est-ce que c'est pas déjà trop tard pour
se poser la question ah non pas du tout
je pense que ça va très V tout le monde
est en train de l'adopter c'est ce que
vous nous dites tout le monde est en
train de l'adopter mais il est jamais
trop tard je pense qu'il faut faire
attention à pas prendre des décisions
effs de communation soit par peur d'êre
doublé par la concurrence faut être
raisonnable faut peut-être à
l'élaboration de ch à l'échelle
d'entreprise ça ça peut être un premier
pas pour associer aussi les citoyens et
les employés à cette réflexion
démocratique je rejoins Mar sur ce point
après ce qui est intéressant c'est
effectivement qu'est-ce qu'on gagne
comme temps pour faire quoi on a c'est
la grande promesse de l'histoire
technologique gagner du temps gagner du
temps de cerveau disponible pour se
libérer faire des activités plus
créatives plus
la réalité c'est aussi qu'on a jamais eu
autant de spam et de mail à gérer qu'on
a jamais eu autant de réunions qui
servent à rien que dans plein de métiers
en fait ce tempsl s'est rempli d'une
manière qui était pas forcément
souhaitable donc il a un
vrai une vraie réflexion à mener à
l'échelle de chaque quasiment de chaque
entreprise sur effectivement le
périmètre idéal d'un usage de
l'intelligence artificielle votre avis
la sur Sébastien Carbonel est-ce que
c'est effectivement à la dimension de
chaque entreprise est-ce que c'est au
état de de de définir finalement cette
cet usage de l'intelligence artificielle
et ce à quoi on utilise le temps gagner
oui je je veux revenir sur un exemple
qui ne porte pas directement sur
l'intelligence artificielle mais qui
nous concerne toutes et tous c'est celui
du télétravail le télétravail a été
présenté comme une révolution aussi dans
le monde du travail la possibilité que
des individus par exemple n'ai pas à se
rendre au travail et donc qu'il gagne
tout ce temps de transport pour
justement des loisirs mais la plupart
des enquêtes notamment celle de la DARES
qui est la direction de l'animation de
la Recherche du Ministère du travail
montre que ce temps de transport qui a
été pris par le salarié ensuite a été
transformé en temps de travail avec
beaucoup d'effets négatifs sur la santé
sur par exemple des troubles de sommeil
des problèmes dans le fait de tenir une
posture beaucoup plus longtemps des
choses comme ça et on voit bien comment
une technologie qui est présentée comme
potentiellement émancipatrice qui
libérerait des individus euh les
aliennent d'autant plus oui voilà
exactement nous aliennent d'autant plus
ou nous soumet d'autant plus au travail
oui mais alors là là on revient et je
repose la question sur le périmètre
parce que en fait ça dépend presque de
chaque salarié ce que vous nous décrivez
pour certains le télétravail ça va être
vraiment un progrès vraiment un gain et
cetera pour d'autres ça peut être
aliénant effectivement donc à quel
niveau on on on on décide là je reviens
à la question de l'intelligence
artificielle de la façon dont on
l'utiliser est-ce que c'est entreprise
par entreprise ou est-ce que c'est un
état qui doit prendre cette décision je
pense qu'il un enjeu déjà au niveau de
l'entreprise c'est que les syndicats les
organisations de salariés devrai pouvoir
aussi avoir leur mot à dire sur
l'organisation du travail sur
l'introduction d'une nouvelle
technologie sur quelle technologie doit
être utilisée et aussi sur les effets et
les contreparties à l'introduction d'une
nouvelle technologie donc c'est un
premier début c'est une première échelle
de régulation et je pense que plutôt au
niveau de l'État on doit pas se poser
seulement la question de la régulation
d'un usage mais aussi se poser la
question de on Amand est-ce que des
intelligences artificielles devraient
être introduites devraient prendre ce
genre de décision devrai euh être tout
simplement introdite dans le monde du
travail façon qu'on en a forcément
besoin qu'on a besoin pour tous les
métiers et cetera et Cera des vraies
questions et c'est pour ça que je ris un
peu peut-être que dans certains secteurs
c'est peut-être un peu trop tard déjà
parce que quand la technologie c'est
c'est développé aussi vite bref on va se
concentrer comme promis sur la la
question des métiers créatif vous avez
évoqué les les scénaristes d'Hollywood
je vous propose d'écouter la réaction de
de l'un d'entre eux il s'appelle David
rcliff et il nous parle de cette vitesse
de développement justement de
l'intelligence
artificielle
l'intelligence artificielle va tellement
vite il fallait vraiment faire cette
greffe pour être certain de sécuriser
notre rôle de scénariste avant d'être
remplacé par un truc qu'on ne peut même
pas prévoir donc oui j'ai hâte de voir
ce qui a été
négocié parce que la touche humaine de
la création artistique ne peut pas être
mise de
côté voilà pour ce témoignage
américain il y a évidemment beaucoup
d'artistes qui monte au créneau certains
vont jusqu'à demander l'interdiction de
l'intelligence artificielle pour leur
métier regardez cette tribune publié
dans le journal Libération un collectif
international d'artistes de créateurs de
traducteurs aussi vous évoquez les les
traducteurs je vais citer quelques noms
Luc Darden shimamandangzi adishian kibal
agès de Sart qui font partie des des
signataires voilà ce qu'ils disent on
refuse tout recours enfin il demande de
d'interdire le recours àia dans la
littérature le cinéma où les jeux vidéo
l'usage menace les savoir-faire et
prépare je les cite un avenir saturé de
contenu uniformisé votre avis là-dessus
Marion carré faut-il aller jusque là
peut-on aller jusque là moi la question
elle est plus sur quelle dose
d'intelligence artificielle est où c'est
vrai que ce risque de l'uniformisation
si on se remet aux intelligigences
artificielles pour faire tous les choix
de production et que bah bien évidemment
elles vont nous proposer ce qui a
fonctionné le plus par le passé on
arrive dans ce type de problématique je
pense que c'est important de faire
confiance aux expertises humaines et
effectivement d'aller s'en servir pour
un certain niveau d'assistance là on
estime que ce temps peut être mieux
investi ailleurs mais je pense qu'il y a
un enjeu de c'est nous les experts en
tant qu'humains et il faut pas tout
remettre entre les mains de
l'intelligence artificielle donc c'est
plus un enjeu de dosage mais quand on
prend par exemple le le le le dessin on
voit aujourd'hui des dessins faits par
intelligence artificielle qui peuvent
être magnifiques euh est-ce qu'il faut
aller jusqu'à les interdire est-ce qu'il
faut informer nous informer euh
de de l'origine finalement blaz Mao ce
dessin c'est un dessin 100 % Ia ce
dessin c'est un dessin un peu d'IA et
puis il y a quand même un humain qui qui
a utilisé l'outil voyez ce que je veux
dire avec une information par-dessus on
a déjà des informations sur les produits
en supermarché on va avoir des
information moi c'est une vraie question
j'écoute un morceau de musique je
aujourd'hui on est bombardé tous les
jours je sais pas combien de de de de
dizaines de milliers de de de nouvelles
chansons qui qui sortent et certaines
sont 100 % intelligence artificielle je
sais pas forcment quand je quand je
l'écoute on est submergé c'est l'objet
du nouveau livre de Bruno Patino c'est
le bon terme je pense et le choix est
devenu de plus en plus difficile et de
fait on délègue de plus en plus le choix
de nos consommations culturelles
notamment à des intelligences
artificielles ce qui est intéressant je
pense c'est de voir que c'est ces
recettes de l'IA dans la narration dans
l'écriture de scénario par exemple elles
existent déjà elles existaient déjà
avant les IA elles sont déjà déployé
aujourd'hui la plupart des productions
Netflix répondent par exemple à des
codes d'écriture extrêmement scripté ex
précis moi ce que je trouve intéressant
c'est de voir qu'il y a une mobilisation
alors 5 mois ça paraît très long et les
les studios étaient en panique parce que
ça coûte très cher cette grève mais 5
mois c'est finalement assez peu pour
obtenir des des des vrais acquis du côté
des scénaristes on verra si les acteurs
obtennent aussi on se pose jamais la
question de la qualité vous vous parlez
de par exemple de musique faite par lia
mais est-ce que c'est aussi qualitatif
que musique créée par un homme est-ce
qu'un texte ça dépend il a y a des
mauvais c'est une question
bon il a des tub il y a des tubes qu'on
peut juger mauvais dans la le qualité
pourtant ça a touché le grand public
vous voyez ce que je veux dire donc
interroger François Pachet de Spotify
qui est le le monsieur Ia de Spotify qui
nous disait que aucune chanson composée
à 100 % par uneia n'avait jamais fait
pleurer quelqu'un voilà peuttre
peut-être ser ce qui est intéressant je
trouve c'est de voir que confronté à des
problématiques de remplacement ces
métiers là se sont mobilisés très vite
et ont obtenu très vite des concessions
là les scénaristes on parle de si des
scénarios ont été généré par Unia et qu'
les retravaillent ils en sont considérés
comme le seul auteur à l'avenir ils
auront la même rémunération donc ça a
été une belle
négociation de même que les la question
des des IA qui sont entraînés en fait
sur des œuvres et ils ont obtenu
qu'elles ne soi pas entraîné sur des
œuvres qui ont été créées par des des
scénaristes syndqués alors ouais ça
touche beaucoup d'autres métiers du du
cinéma il y a les cascadeurs par exemple
parce que en fait lia permet de recréer
l'image d'un cascadeur notamment en fond
en fond de on va dire en fond de plan et
donc ils ont peur les cascadeurs que
finalement
bah on capte leur mouvement et puis que
ce soit recréé et et d'une façon assez
bluffante par l'intelligence
artificielle et puis il y a les acteurs
regardez ce post sur Instagram signé Tom
Hanks c'est pas le plus mauvais et le
moins connu des acteurs mondiaux il
alerte sur une fausse publicité qui
circule qui utilise son image sans son
consentement je crois que c'est pour une
un spot qui a été créé grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle ran
Sébastien Carbonel est-ce que on on se
prépare à des mouvements sociaux en
cascade dans tous les métiers créatifs
en quelque sorte eu pas forcément enfin
comment dire moi je j'aimerais bien
revenir sur cette grève de scénariste
dans le sens où c'est pas que une grève
contre l'intelligence artificielle mais
c'est aussi une grève contre un
changement dans le modèle économique de
la production de séries parce que ce que
disent la plupart des scénaristes c'est
des grevist c'est que auparavant les
séries duraient très longtemps les
scénaristes travaillaient sur 40
semaines et grâce au nouveau modèles du
streaming en réalité euh ils travaillent
moins longtemps jusqu'à 20 semaines et
donc ils se sont trouvés à chercher
beaucoup plus de travail entre des
périodes de chômage beaucoup plus
longues et cetera donc il faut toujours
avoir à l'esprit que c'est pas des
grèves exclusivement contre les
nouvelles technologies mais ce sont
aussi des grèves qui se mobilisent
contre un modèle économique qui sont
portés par ces nouvelles technologies
vous voyez ce que je veux dire bien sûr
et de la même façon le on l'a vu euh
lorsque les premières machines ont été
introduites avec le mouvement did et
ludit c'est ces briseurs de machines les
briseurs de machines ne se mobilisaient
pas contre les machines on a retenu deux
et c'est parce que l'histoire est très
condescendante contre les perdants on a
retenu deux justement le fait de
détruire des machines mais aussi se
mobiliser contre la dégradation de leur
travail contre la dégradation des
produits également beaucoup de d'entre
eux travaillaient dans le textile et
cetera il voyaient ce nouveau textile de
mauvaise qualité et donc qui se'est
mobiliser aussi contre un nouveau modèle
économique alors il il y a un thème très
important on a commencé à l'aborder mais
on va y consacrer du temps dans dans ce
débat un vrai chapitre dans notre dans
notre émission c'est l'action des
gouvernements de l'Union européenne
qu'est-ce qui peut être fait qu'est-ce
qui est déjà fait Létitia on commence
avec vous l'Union européenne qui a
adopté une loi intelligence artificielle
qui vise à on va dire réglementer le
secteur oui ça date de 2021 donc c'est
pas tout récent et puis on continue à
discuter dans l'Union européenne hein le
Parlement la Commission les
États-membres on est en pleine
discussion sur l'IA il y a déjà des
mesures restrictives qui ont été votées
dans cette ila Act c'est quoi l'idée de
cette loi bah c'est l'idée c'est de
faire une une classification en fonction
des risques oui de nouvelles
technologies qu'on ne connaît pas encore
qui vont arriver sur le marché donc en
fonction du risque elles sont autorisées
ou pas par exemple reconnaissance
faciale tout de suite ça a été interdit
il y a aussi la cotation sociale vous
savez noté ça fait alors je fais un
petit aparté mais l'objet d'un génial
épisode de Black Mirror notation sociale
comme ça donc ça ça a été interdit c'est
ce qui existe en Chine notamment voilà
donc on comprend bien que c'est un
gardefou quand même contre un
développement anarchique de l'IA qui
viendrait remplacer tous les humains et
puis voler tous les tous les jobs qui
est en charge chaque État son son Mo
dire c'est ça là ça pose un tout petit
peu problème parce que chaque État est
chargé de contrôler voilà la régularité
des technologies de l' en France ça
devrait être la knil qui devrait s'en
charger d'accord et Bruno Le Maire pose
les les enjeux il il est rentré dans le
débat de de l'intelligence artificielle
européenne c'était cet été pour nous
dire quoi pour nous dire alors il nous
parle pas du tout du tout de régulation
et de réglementation on va l'écouter il
est un peu comme ça un petit peu dans
l'épopée on va dire bon du siècle de
guerre économique contre les GTA juillet
c'était aux rencontres économiqu de ex
en Provence l'intelligence artificielle
générative va nous permettre pour la
première fois depuis plusieurs
générations de retrouver de la
productivité d'être plus efficace je
plaide donc avant de poser les bases de
la régulation l'intelligence
artificielle que nous fassions de
l'innovation que nous investissions et
que nous nous fixions comme objectif
d'avoir un open ai européen sous 5 ans
avec les calculateurs les scientifiques
et les algorithmes nécessaires c'est
bon ça s'appelle du volontarisme
politique laticia oui on sent l'emphase
et c'est vrai que c'est c'est t temp
quand même d'arrimer la France à ce
projet qui semble total et puis qui
finalement va aller sur la scène
mondiale concurrencer les GF mais tout
n'est pas faux Thomas parce que
figurez-vous que quand on parle de
réglementation pour le moment lia
générative comme chat GPT dont on parle
depuis tout à l'heure échappe à la
réglementation parce qu'elle n'entre
dans aucune catégor de l' Act de l'Union
européenne et en France par exemple C
plaintes sont déposées là encore déposé
à laakil contre chat GPT BL ma on sait
que par exemple sur la protection des
données l'Europe a plutôt est d'ailleurs
toujours en en pointe et que les les
règlements qui ont été votés ou les lois
les actes ont été votés au niveau
européen finissent par s'imposer parfois
difficilement mais finissent par
s'imposer notamment aux grandes
entreprises mondiales est-ce que ça peut
être la même le même cas de figure sur
les questions d'intelligence
artificielle est est-ce que l'Union
européenne peut être un peu à la pointe
d'une réglementation d'un contrôle c'est
l'idée mais le résultat sera pas
spectaculaire comme le rgpd le fameux
règlement général sur la protection des
données n'était pas spectaculaire en
fait c'est une sorte de bouclier c'est
une approche
défensive de la donnée là c'est la même
quasiment la même démarche appliquée à
l'IA et donc évidemment il faut essayer
d'accorder les pays membres il faut
essayer d'amener une vision nationale
dans cette négociation ce qui est très
compliqué il y a 5 ans Bruno le on
disait qu'il fallait faire un gaff à
européen et que la France pourrait en
être le berceau on est très loin du
compte donc c'est très difficile en fait
de de d'amener je dirais une vision
française de l'IA dans cette dans cette
réflexion là après les pays européens
sont assez accordés sur les objectifs et
je trouve que les plateformes
américaines les géants type Google
Microsoft les Gafa les gafem on va dire
euh
envisage grâce au précédent qui était un
peu violent du rgpd pour eux envisage ce
cet i Act avec pas mal de de je vais pas
dire de bienveillance euh mais je dirais
de en tout cas de de diplomatie ce qui
ce qui est assez nouveau Marion carry il
y a il y a que des acteurs puissants
américains sur le marché de
l'intelligence artificielle ou alors il
y a des Chinois il y a des il y a l'Inde
il y a enfin voyez ce que ce que je veux
dire est-ce que est-ce que c'est c'est
vraiment dominé par la par les
États-Unis effectivement on a une sur
l'intelligence artificielle générative
il y a deux niveaux à retenir il y a le
niveau des modèles de fondation qui sont
principalement entre les mains de géants
américains et et aussi de plus en plus
chinois et donc c'est vrai qu'il y a une
concentration des ressources de ce
côté-là et après il y a au niveau des
applications où là il y a des
entreprises de de tout bord qui
développent des des usages de
l'intelligence artificielle appliqué à
des problématiques métiers plus
spécifiques mais donc c'est vrai que
pour l'instant on a quand même une
concentration et ça c'est aussi lié à
l'aspect des données puisque les grands
ensembles de données qui sont
nécessaires pour entraîner ces modèles
sont souvent captés par les mêmes
acteurs ah oui ça ne pouvait être que
ces géants déjà installés de des des
nouvelles technologies qui pouvaient
apprendre aux machines c'est ce que je
comprends hein c'est ça il fallait une
base une base de données je dis avec mes
mots à moi mais suffisamment vaste pour
que ça ça fonctionne effectivement il y
a un enjeu des des nourrir de millions
et millions de données c'est vrai que
quand on en a déjà capté depuis
plusieurs années c'est plus facile bon
et ça pose quand même une vraie question
de
souveraineté la France qui veut monter
dans le le train de l'intelligence
artificielle si j'ose dire regardez la
Une des écho ce matin nous notre thème
on l'a lancé il y a plusieurs jours ça
tombe bien les échos sont sur la même
ligne ligne intelligence artificielle
l'offensive de Paris des fonds étrangers
qui investissent dans nos start-up des
étudiants talentueux un objectif faire
grandir un écosystème stratégique on va
en parler tout de suite avec Quentin
calm vous pouvez nous nous rejoindre de
nouveau sur ce plateau Quentin rebonsoir
puisque on va se concentrer un peu sur
l'action du gouvernement français qui a
lancé une réflexion importante à ce
sujet ça a été annoncé il y a quelques
semaines exactement je voulais commencer
par vous lire une citation si vous
voulez bien Thomas l'arrivée récente de
l'intelligence artificielle au cœur de
notre quotidien a révélé le potentiel de
cet outil numérique et soulève de très
nombreuses questions c'est ce qu'écrit
Matignon dans un communiqué il y a
quelques jours avec ce paradoxe
effectivement entre opportunité et
inquiétude de l'autre côté que la
première ministre et bien a lancé donc
c'était le 20 septembre un premier le
tout premier comité sur l'intelligence
artificielle avec plusieurs ministrees
autour de la table on a vu celui du
numérique c'est logique mais aussi Bruno
Le Maire le ministre de l'économie ou
encore le garde des saau c'est peut-être
plus inattendu Éric Dupont Moretti et
écoutez lorsque isisabeth borne a
présenté ce comité c'était devant le
meddef en août dernier et notre objectif
c'est d'abord de maîtriser toute la
chaîne de valeur des algorithmes au
super calculateur c'est d'anticiper
aussi les impacts économiques et sociaux
et puis c'est de protéger à la fois les
créateurs et puis les données
personnelles donc c'est toute une
stratégie que nous devons mener qui
concerne beaucoup de secteurs c'est pour
ça que comme l'a proposé Bruno Le Maire
moi je vais créer un conseil stratégique
de l'intelligence artificielle que je
présiderai qui nous permettra de prendre
en compte la globalité de tous ces
sujets alors on parle d'un d'un comité
de 15 personnes qu'il compos et bien il
s'agit d'acteurs du privé comme
d'experts de personnalités français et
international on pense à Cédric ha
ancien ministre du numérique ou encore
du directeur actuel directeur général de
dasso système ou encore d'une
syndicaliste de la CFDT spécialisé sur
ces sujets car il va être notamment
question d'emploi avec ce comité c'est
un des quatre même cinq thème sur
lesquels ils vont plancher regardez il y
a d'abord la souveraineté française
ensuite l'impact sur l'économie et
l'emploi on en parlait les questions
éthiques et sociétales et aussi les
conséquences sur les services publics et
enfin les conséquences sur la culture
avec un un comité aussi consacré à ce
thème qui sera rattaché à ce à ce ce
comité principal résultat des travaux
Thomas dans 6 mois en mince avec des
propositions concrètes promettent les
administrateurs de ce comité on verra
d'ailleurs s'il y a des dispositions
législatives dans la Foulet qui sont
proposé merci beaucoup Quentin je me
tourne forcément vers vous Mar car parce
que vous faites partie justement de ce
de cette on va dire branche culture qui
va travailler autour de ce comité
qu'est-ce qu'on peut en attendre c'est
quoi l'idée générale définir une voie
française en quelque sorte alors
effectivement le l'enjeu c'est de
pouvoir faire un tour d'horizon des
enjeux et à la fois donc que ce soit des
problématiques mais aussi des
opportunités pour pouvoir arriver avec
des proposition justement concrète
vis-à-vis de de ces enjeux-l parce que
la ligne et on en parlait tout à l'heure
c'est vrai qu'il y a à la fois beaucoup
d'opportunités à saisir et en même temps
le fait de protéger un certain nombre de
d'acteurs et je pense que c'est toute la
complexité de de ce sujet d' à la fois
réussir à s'en emparer et en même temps
de protéger les les acteurs pour qui
c'est nécessaire est-ce qu'il français
pour vous parce que voilà ce qu'on sent
derrière là dans les dans les propos de
Bruno ler tout à l'heure ou là de la
première ministre il a une volonté de de
est-ce qu'il y a un retard et est-ce qu'
est-ce qu'il y a une volonté de le
rattraper je pense qu'il y a un enjeu
tout va très vite c'est ce qu'on était
en train de de se dire et donc il y a un
enjeu de effectivement prendre le le
train en marche continuer à avancer
continuer à identifier les les enjeux
tout à l'heure vous me posiez la
question de qu'est-ce que peuvent faire
les Français vis-à-vis de ça je pense
qu'il y a vraiment un enjeu de se former
en fait et d'identifier les besoins en
formation dans les différentes filières
pour pouvoir permettre effectivement de
de ne pas avoir de fracture entre les
personnes formées non formées celles qui
sont saisissent et et les autres qui
former pour travailler avec exactement
se former pour travailler avec des IA
c'est quelque chose de je pense assez
important et notamment aussi se former à
qu'est-ce qu'on peut attendre ou non
d'une intelligence artificielle
générative parce que il y a un effet un
peu baguette magique et c'est vrai qu'on
a l'impression que ça peut absolument
tout faire alors qu'il y a un enjeu de
comprendre quels sont les les bons
usages le bon niveau euh euh et où
placer l' générative au bon endroit mais
ran Sébastien carbonal est-ce que c'est
pas quand même un gigantesque braquage
auquel on a assisté parce que finalement
pour pour nourrir ces ces ces
intelligences artificielles génératives
bah ils ont été puisés dans ce que tant
de cerveaux humains ont créé inventé
depuis euh depuis des décennies oui sans
forcément payer les droits absolument
euh c'est pour ça que certains collègues
parlent de des za comme des machines
interprétative h c'est-à-dire le fait
que c'est enfin ces machines utilisent
les les capacités d'interprétation de
tout être humain qui existe d'ailleurs
dans non seulement les métiers
intellectuels mais aussi dans tout
métier euh manuel euh frapper un clou
avec un marteau nécessite également de
l'interprétation et pas seulement de la
force physique mais dans les métiers
qualifiés euh ce travail est un peu plus
complexe un peu différent ou et donc ces
machines interprétatives elles
exproprient en quelque sorte ou du moins
ellellees capte ses compétences les
standardisent et ensuite on les répète
on les réplique sous la forme d'une d'un
algorithme d'une intelligence
artificielle donc oui c'est euh
algorithmes peuvent faire ce que
nous-mêmes nous faisons mais je dirais
toujours un peu moins bien c'estàdire
que il y a tout un tas de tâches que les
machines ne pourront peut-être jamais
faire comme les ordinateurs dans les
années 80 absolument peut mais peut-être
que un jour ces ces machines euh ces
intelligences artificielles ces robots à
intelligence artificielle vont peut-être
remplacer les patrons pour regarder la
la la question des des des managers et
des tâches de managers qui peuvent être
remplacé par l'intelligence artificielle
regardez on a deux deux éléments euh à
apporter au débat d'abord ces im
Mika c'est le le surnom donné par une
intelligence artificielle qui vient
d'être nommé PDG expérimental par une
entreprise polonaise j'essayie de ne pas
rigoler la technologie en phase d'essai
est jugée précieuse pour son expertise
en analyse de données mais certaines
décisions importantes ouf reste quand
même entre les mains des dirigeants
humains cet autre robot qui est lui
développé par Hanson Robotics prénommé
sopia vente écoutez bien son efficacité
pour prendre les bonnes
décisions je pense que les robots
humanoïdes ont le potentiel pour dirigé
et avec un niveau d'efficacité supérieur
à celui des humains nous n'avons pas les
mêmes préjugés ni d'émotions qui peuvent
parfois obscurcir la prise de décision
et puis nous pouvons traiter rapidement
de grandes quantités de données afin de
prendre les meilleures décisions PLMA
c'est une question presque philosophique
ça est-ce que l'intelligence
artificielle peut prendre de meilleures
décisions à la dimension d'une
entreprise par exemple et d'un patron ou
d'un cadre dirigeant elle peut prendre
des décisions d'optimisation et elle
peut prendre des décisions basées sur
une obsession de la productivité et
c'est là où c'est potentiellement
dangereux ouis après une IA et notamment
les génératifs dont on parle depuis tout
à l'heure ne vont pas combler nos
lacunes des des As génératives ne
peuvent pas remplacer des enseignants ne
peuvent pas remplacer du personnel
soignant dans les hôpitaux ça c'est
c'est quand même important c'est
intéressant parliez de la santé parce
que alors je chaque fois qu'on fait un
débat sur l' je ressors la question des
radiologues j'ai pas d'obsession sur ce
métier mais c'est vrai que l'œil de
l'ordinateur est plus précis que l'œil
humain de gris mais oui mais est-ce
qu'il y a besoin est-ce qu'il y aura
besoin d'autant de radiologue ah je
pense qu'il faut un radiologue derrière
pour analyser mettre mettre en regard
croiser comparer bien sûr c'est comme
les juristes ils vont pouvoir se
débarrasser entre guillemets de tout un
tas de tâches peut-être pas très
rigolotes quand on est clair de notire
ok mais allez je pousse les arguments
sauf que quand on est médecin il y a
toujours le le la crainte parce que
c'est vrai qu'il y a c'est c'est on est
une société de plus en plus judiciarisée
donc là il y a la crainte du procès le
médecin le radiologue qui va oser aller
contre le euh le le la la perception le
diagnostique je cherchais le mot de
l'intelligence artificielle pour dire
elle s'est peut-être trompé je vais
prendre une autre décision faudrait
qu'il ait un bon avocat bah voilà on est
bien d'accord donc c'est enfin voilà on
est dans c'est dans dans dans c'est un
métier à réinventer aussi d'une certaine
façon je je fais une blague mais c'est
vrai que c'est tout est à réinventer
bien sûr la la question mais on l'a vu
avec la question de la consultation la
téléconsultation qui allait être
dramatique on allait perdre le rapport
humain et c'est vrai que ça pose des
vrais problèmes je pense de dans les
dans les zonees isolées dans les
campagnes la la le manque de proximité
du personnel soignant mais on s'adapte
avec ces technologies là on apprend les
utiliser moi je pense qu'il y a vraiment
il y a vraiment en tout cas sur ces
métiers-là euh il y aura pas de de de
remplacement ils peuvent nous aider euh
oui c'est un outil extraordinaire ah oui
non mais bien sûr que c'est un outil
extraordinaire ça peut permettre de
progresser et je pense qu'on sera tous
en meilleure santé en partie grâce à cet
outil mais ran Sébastien Carbonel je je
voudrais parce que il y a une question
qui a été posée par un des témoins du du
du du sujet d'ouverture de notre débat
donc de cette entreprise à courbevie qui
disait ok euh ça va peut-être créer des
emplois mais pas ici
pas en France qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ça
euh c'est vrai que c'est un problème du
moins tous les discours sur le futur du
travail la disparition des emplois et
surtout des emplois manuels sont des
discours assez eurocentrés c'estàdire
qu'il se focalisent exclusivement à ce
qui se passe en Europe aux États-Unis
dans les pays du Nord et ils sont assez
aveigles à un phénomène qui est assez
évident pourtant qui est une
augmentation du nombre de travailleurs
manuels à l'échelle mondiale c'estàdire
que si aujourd'hui il y a moins de
travail d'ailleurs dans l'industrie
automobile française il y en a beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup plus en Chine au
Mexique en Europe de l'Est en Turquie et
de plus en plus au Magreb où on fabrique
la plupart des véhicules qu'on consomme
sauf qu'on est en train d'essayer de
relocaliser on essae mais la l'évidence
pour le moment dans la plupart des
études montrent qu'il y a peu ou pas de
relocalisation sauf dans certains
secteurs de niche où précisément la
proximité avec le consommateur est
importante mais donc alors attendez je
vais vous je vais conclure avec vous
hein juste pour aller au bout ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on
accepte de renoncer à certains méti pour
en faire d'autres c'est-àdire bah c'està
dire on laisse des métiers à d'autres
parties du monde et ou alors on devient
un continent de de dooisif qui qui
profitent des loisirs enfin voilà c'est
une vraie question de société là aussi
c'est une question beaucoup plus
compliquée que ça dans le sens où de la
même façon qu'on voit des métiers
industriels disparaître de la France on
voit d'autres métiers industriels
apparaître toujours en France notamment
dans le secteur de la logistique
aujourd'hui il y a autour de 800000
emplois ouvriers dans la logistique ce
qui est fois plus que le nombre
d'emplois industriels dans l'industrie
automobile donc on voit bien que c'est
pas qu'une question de disparition des
métiers industriels mais aussi
l'apparition de nouveaux métiers
industriels également en France merci
beaucoup merci à tous c'était vraiment
passionnant de de de vous entendre et de
voilà de se nourrir de votre expertise
sur ces thématiques bla Mao je vais
renvoyer à votre magazine usbec et Rica
qui traite régulièrement de ces de ces
thématiques merci à tous d'avoir
participé encore une fois à ce débat
demain on célébrera les 65 ans de la
constitution de la 5e République CEA ce
sera l'un des thèmes de notre émission
et ce sera aussi le thème de l'interview
politique de la matinale puisque demain
Oriane mansini reçoit l'ancien président
du Conseil constitutionnel Jean-Louis
Debray je vous souhaite une très belle
soirée sur Public Sénat merci de votre
[Musique]
fidélité